I play a decent amount of math second
drama de Jean Luc's psyche who's on our
TriCaster right now
prettiest around this show has played I
think the most out of anybody no no
Scott so Scott Butterworth has been home
playing reviewing it I don't know how
far he is in the game I haven't talked
to him I don't know what he thinks about
it but we can only talk about the intro
and the first like open world-ish so to
speak segment sure so like people if
you're familiar with Pete Brown he
sometimes can be voice of what reason to
you have you temper my enthusiasm
sometimes and I have to temper your
curmudgeonly yeah there's there's a
common theme on the show are you asking
if I've played a game or a series before
and I say no and it typically tends to
be just games that I just don't really
have much interest in yeah so coming
into Mass Effect I thought right this is
my chance to like give the series a shot
I'm not worried about coming to Shepherd
and all this stuff so I'm gonna jump in
and I'm really looking forward to
playing it so when I'm coming in with my
assessment versus people who have played
all the Mass Effect games and are
accustomed to all the things this game
does there are very different
conversations happening in the office
right where yeah where I come in with
this sort of sort of fresh eyes fresh
perspective on this whole thing and I
see a lot of things that bother me it
was like well yeah but that's that's
massive fact that's Bioware like okay
that's what I said first but I play more
of it
yeah it's getting harder and harder to
excuse some of these things it's not
that I was excusing him to begin with
but it was just like you were saying
like I was like all right it's Bioware
its mass effect like I was kind of
expecting this to happen but there are
certain things that I wasn't expecting
to happen that did that left me
disappointed even from those first two
hours we can talk about right now based
on that embargo that Bioware gave us
it's it doesn't even feel the more plate
or the more I played it it doesn't even
feel like a Bioware game it's it's weird
I like the combat but I don't like the
characters at least in those first two
hours and I don't like the writing
you're you show up in this different
galaxy you have a world of opportunity
before you what do you want to do with
this and you land on this
crash land on this foreign planet and
you're like there's this one quote from
this dude who is just pissed off and the
first thing you do you know you jump
into combat and this guy's shooting over
and over at this point although you were
concerned that I was gonna be the one
together plant and we're right after
this I'm gonna talk about our favorite
Bioware RPGs in general because they
have done some great stuff in the past
to say the least but yeah you land on
this planet and it looks cool and this
stuttering you're seeing I don't even I
don't know if that is the stream or the
game because this game is so this the
facial animations it's I think Jean
there's just China he said it was the
game is the game yeah that wasn't our
stream hiccuping that was the game it's
we talked about how awesome it is if
they just like flail their fingers they
speak to it with sign language and it
heals their visors but it's okay let me
get it
I feel like you're struggling articulate
here so let me jump in remember how much
I can't talk about rez yeah I got more
and I don't like pastors first
so I've literally only played what we're
allowed to talk about because well
didn't compel the plane boy no I I it's
gonna sound cruel but the experience was
intolerable for me i controlling the
characters themselves is it's such a
frustrating experience because it seems
as though they were animated in a way to
mimic real life like momentum and
movement but that doesn't mean it's fun
or even the a good way to control our
video game character and again taking a
game so when I push forward and it takes
the character like half a second or two
to wind up and then I let go the stick
and they're still kind of moving forward
and stuff like okay I don't feel like I
have really tight control over my
character that was kind of my first
problem didn't feel that at all no the
character move maybe it's cuz I played
so much with The Witcher and like sure
character movement was kind of an issue
for a while until they annexed it but
like I I
especially in combat I think the
movement feels pretty good I dunno what
you're saying it's good in combat when
you have your weapon out yeah I will I
will say that problem is pretty much
gone at that point but like I guess when
you're in ty
spaces I guess it it could feel a little
bit smoother but yeah like that hasn't
been an issue like I have issues with
this game but the movement for me know
what do I then really push platforming
on you and here's this GD scanner you
like it doesn't give you anything cool
to read like horizon I think did a good
job using it the focus the thing on
Eli's head that allows her to like
investigate things kind of a la Arkham
Asylum and they did a good job of not
keeping you in it the whole time because
it slows your movement so you want to
get out of it and see this gorgeous
world they made and this looks cool that
everything I'm seeing right now tells me
it looks like a Mass Effect game you
know you're exploring these new world
you're in a whole new galaxy you don't
know what's going on you come into it
after oh I forget how many 600 something
years of cryo 634 years the Kraus you
see ya after starts after mass spec 2
when they send the Andromeda initiative
with the Pathfinders and everything to
find new places to live they don't I
don't even know at that point if they
know about the whole Reaper thing I
really like the original trilogy I love
the original trilogy I played each of
those games twice Mass Effect 2 is one
of my favorite games and I'm not seeing
the things I was expecting to in this
game I'm not seeing the characters I
like right off the bat and a lot of Mass
Effect games you know well know the
starting characters were always kind of
shitty but yeah so I mean the two
characters you start with for your
squadmates aren't that great like one of
them I've kind of warmed up to but the
other one like if I accidentally end up
with him party my gosh it and I like
back out and like reload and change cuz
it's just boring I don't I don't want
him in there mhm
but the two alien characters that you
meet kind of near the end I think are PB
Iraq and Drac I think they're way more
in Sandwich but still like the writing
is still kind of weak like I think
they're interesting but still like the
dialogue it extends to the plot as well
like in the beginning of the game
there's a pretty significant thing that
happens and something is thrust upon you
and it just like it happens so fast and
and the weight that you then carry does
not feel like the characters earned it
in any way well if we're playing here
does she whatever bet yeah in my
experience this game is just kind of
like guess what this thing happened now
you have to deal with it and
the character doesn't seem to like even
like care mm-hmm
yeah everyone around him is they look
like they care for the wrong reason cuz
their eyes are creepy and their eyes are
very creepy there's really poor lighting
on the eyes everyone looks like there's
just dolls that have like some sort of
like weird like seizures happening yeah
yeah again if you're just joining or if
you've missed it when I said earlier
this is based on like the first couple
hours so I have played much more than
that at this point and I think Jake you
said you played past that as well yeah
about an hour past it and I really
really hope that I will get to the end
of this game be like wow thank God that
it got better after those first two
hours and thank God I got a it was
phenomenal after that's what I'm hoping
I'm not like I don't want this gamey bad
but a lot of small things it seems like
it just feels like rushed like we were
worried about like you know like I don't
know how what might have come down from
ei or I don't know what happened you
know there's like studio shifting which
happens in triple-a development sure
Bioware Montreal worked on this this is
their first game as a studio you know
like from there yeah I'm uh Edmonton
worked on the trilogy I think that sorry
I think the like one thing that I mean
we've only played the beginning and I
think the beginning is very slow like
that I think it does sort of pick up and
I think I kind of overlooked the slow
beginning because I know these
characters or I don't know these
characters but I know this universe I'm
curious what they're gonna do and they
get to Andromeda I want to know the
politics I want to know what's going on
but I do understand at the same time
that this is what like year this is your
first Mass Effect game and you probably
don't give a [ __ ] like who these like
what is going on well the clay isn't
making me give a [ __ ] yeah exactly
that's the problem so it's like talk
about the UI like small decisions that
they seem like if they had more time
they could have fixed it's the the UI is
just about it okay it's super dense and
it doesn't do a really good job of
explaining like how you go about
accomplishing or even managing all the
things that are available to you like it
introduces like very quickly like okay
here all these classes and these
profiles of in these classes you can
customize all this stuff but like I
don't know what to choose right like
yeah the freedom is great but like I
have no clue if like what I'm making is
a smart decision for my own desires as a
player or not it's
it's very difficult to feel like I have
any grasp of what the game is giving me
it's also the fact that in the world
itself it feels just like I'm going
between these cat
I remember a big complaint with Halo 4
which is such a weird comparison but I
remember like people like you're just
pressing switches and shooting people so
what I'm doing here I don't I'm going
between these consoles that will raise
these platforms that I can jump jet up
on to this thing to scan this glyph to
do this like Sudoku like hacking puzzle
and we'll love that hacking puzzle
though let's talk about character
creation that's the first thing you run
into in this game yeah and the default
heroes are the female I think is more of
a heroic face if you will like more of
an iconic look the male looks really
generic and strange so you say okay I'll
make my own character you are given the
the strangest-looking presets to work
from I don't know how it looks like so
much worse than the the characters you
start out with it's yeah I I don't
understand like that was like with the
other Mass Effect games you had like
Commander Shepard like the generic Wing
Commander Shepard but you could mold him
in like it still worked it still looked
good yeah and it seems like with this
they're kind of designed for like the
story is designed for those characters
yeah and their animations well when you
make your character you just feel like
you're getting like I don't know like a
cheaper version of the experience
because I made a character I thought
okay this I like the way this character
looks I'm gonna go with that so I jump
into the game and Vince the gauls
estranged nephew yeah one look at this
baby in one okay you can take him
Lachelle sorry that's fine anyway when
you make your custom character an you go
in the game even if you think they look
great the like the depth of field like
changes in the camera or something
because the dimensions look way
different to me like when I got into the
game relative to my character's body and
the first time they open their mouth I
was like oh god I hate the way their
face is moving right now I had to go
back and make a new character people
people to chat there's someone in the
chat I didn't see a name said if you're
complain about the presets
don't use them the character creation
doesn't give me better options look at
that it doesn't know and and it's really
bad and every everything is like this
dial like even if you're going through
hairstyles and I'm sorry you know what
it is I don't know what generation you
want to call this yeah physical beards
on your characters if your beards or
textures what that it that is that's
like a decades-old problem that so many
other games have fixed by now this guy
looks like the Andromeda galaxy
equivalent of Dennis Rodman like this is
what he would look like if he was in a
different galaxy we're cute aren't
shaped the same we should do a feature
of people just making characters and you
just trying to figure out their
backstory what are you guys liking about
this game right now because I struggle a
little bit to find something that is
really love thing I do want to talk I do
like the dialogue that I have seen like
I I do I do like some of that like when
once I got to tempest right walk down
there and doing stuff that was cool and
I kind of wish that's all game was for
me but what about you guys outside of
oddly enough I didn't think I'd be
saying this about a Bioware game but the
combat is my favorite part about this
game that makes me nervous though that's
not why I play a board game
yeah and I'm all for like them upsetting
my expectations like look what Zelda did
they just they said they're returned to
the roots but they like kind of that's
upset the Zelda status quo but I mean
that's I mean they don't have to always
do what Bioware has been doing but yeah
just when the most positive thing I've
heard is that the combat is good yeah
but what about everything else that I
wanted yeah because you said I mean
we'll talk about a little more in a few
minutes you said nice and Republic you
really like love code it's not the
combat of that game really well brings
you to it whereas this game I'm playing
more the combat and you know you can
change between whereas before you had to
pick Vanguard Sentinel biotic or you
know Engineer technician or whatever in
the older games this you can swap
between them as profiles down the road
on the fly kind of when you're doing
your loadout before you go on a mission
and I think that actually works pretty
well again you want to figure it out
yeah it's more flexible you kind of mold
your carrots are a little more than than
the characterization lets you but I do
have a question with the combat though
is it like good in general and compared
to
like when you compare it to other kinds
of combat or is it just good for what
you expected from Mass Effect it didn't
feel good to me at first at all I really
didn't like it and even the enemy AI
behavior was so basic it was like I
played halo basic 15-20 years ago it
felt like the original halo terms of
their game has it this has not been 20
years halo was 2001 implies when you're
shooting grounds
III think I think the combat is good and
I think it stands on its own because
there's so much creativity in it like I
don't know like they kind of showed it
off but like you can invest in different
powers and you can use them in different
ways like for this time you can actually
like like with a poll before you just
hit the button and they kind of like fly
yeah this time you can actually pull
them towards you and then you can use
throw and you can throw them really far
which is pretty entertaining and like
there's a lot of cool different
abilities that you can use so that is
one thing I do like I do like the combat
I do like the exploration in the worlds
you visit I don't like pulling out your
little thing and scanning it but I think
the settings are really cool looking
which is something that I think people
will be very happy with because people
who played Mass Effect 1 it was like you
can land on different planets and you
land on a planet and they just be a
different color I do like driving the
Nomad and that's another thing driving
the Nomad is actually if it feels pretty
good it's infinitely better than than
the Mako um one weird thing is that you
have to like turn on all wheel drive I
mean I don't know some people might like
that but I actually like hit a hill and
like you can't go up and you have to
turn it on and then go what what your is
this call it six wheel drive I actually
don't mind that it's Morton you can also
like drop these mines to shift gears for
you I thought you're gonna do the Gimli
quote do these little like hops but it's
fun that you can drive right over rocks
this looks cool to me like it looks kind
of like I don't know I just I love the
like there's active there seems like
there's actually character to these
planets there's a whole lot going on
necessarily like there are side missions
in like points of interest but because
they're sort of you know like
uninhabited uninhabited planets this not
a whole lot going on but I I think the
worlds are interesting
excited to explore more of them yeah I
want to get to a couple questions on
Twitter quick before going to the next
segment so Scott like I said Scott
bought her worth
GameSpy editors at home right now
playing it and he has I'm sure he has
much more in-depth thoughts about this
game than we do I know he's been
plugging away at it I'm I was telling
Jake for some reason I'm looking forward
to playing more and that's not something
I want to say sit with me like it's
weird for some reason I want to play
more of this game and I don't know why I
was playing it last night and I like
kind of didn't really want to play it
that much like I was like I should just
go to bed I don't want it it wasn't
keeping me up all night but now I went
to bed and played Zelda in bed
a little bit oh I get it
empty vessel on YouTube was saying they
complained nothing he's explained but
what Zelda they love that there's no
hand-holding inability explore to your
heart's content
Mass Effect you can't move forward in
this game without these things being
explained it's like Zelda doesn't gate
you from moving forward if you don't
know how to do something it tells you an
intelligent way is later on like 50
hours in the game you can figure out
these cool things you didn't know you
could do in Mass Effect you can't
progress unless you know where this
console is that you have to press a
button on that's gonna raise this
platform to scan this glyph before you
do that another 7 times you can't move
forward in this game unless these things
are explained and they don't do a good
job of explaining I don't need them to
give me a text box which is what they do
if you dig enough for it through this
codex but codec sorry
Mass Effect people gonna be pissed I
just like codex so you corrected
yourself sorry okay I'm fine
you can't it's I'm moving from these
consoles between these consoles to press
buttons and yeah worlds are cool I'm
looking forward to seeing more of these
planets from the first two hours we've
seen EEOC and the The Tempest is your
ship it's like the new versus their
Normandy and then the men coming on the
human Ark and then there's an ark for
each race but yeah the Nexus is the like
new Citadel and I didn't find it that
interesting so you like I don't like the
fact that you are gated by like oh hit
the button on this console and then jump
here and then hit the button on the next
console I don't like that I don't mind
that I don't mind that it's not open
right away like Zelda
like that that doesn't bug me I don't
mind that I am gated I just don't like
the reasons I am gated if that makes
sense like if they found
good way to kind of tie that in like
okay and I think they did with Mass
Effect one and two like the way you
progressed or one two and three the way
you progressed made sense for the most
part and even like one if people
remember like right when you get the
Normandy it's kind of like all right
there's four things you need to do do
however you want to do or however you
want to do it and with this it is a
little bit more linear in that
progression but once again I don't mind
it I just wish they had a more natural
and realistic way of yeah I knew from
area to area right I do want to get to a
couple questions uh Mateus Mucha
apologies if I'm butchering that on
Twitter said is there any variety to
sidequest in Andromeda are they simple
fetch quests or multi-layered ones like
the one in The Witcher 3 Jake is a good
question for you because you love The
Witcher 3 for that reason I mean Ivan
played a lot of the side quests but I do
think they they are much better than
they were in Mass Effect 1 & 2 it's not
like it's not like very simple sort of
like even 3head like somewhere you'd
like being the Citadel and you talk to
this guy be like oh I'll talk to this
guy you talk to that guy and you finish
it mm-hmm like there is more there's a
story to a lot of these but they do have
additional quests yeah
like literally that's what they're
calling a section for like if you're
bored yes so they do get a just quests
like that to the extent of The Witcher 3
no like definitely not so yeah Mateus
thank you for your question Charlotte
Cutts asks do you think that the
criticisms are how graphically polished
the characters are in Andromeda are
justified yes absolutely I think it's an
artistic choice as well that just does
not land I I mean I this is probably my
biggest issue is I mean like I don't a
sound shallow that I just care about the
graphics book presentation was huge in
Mass Effect one two and three like it
doesn't look great now but at the time I
remember like with the whole dialogue
wheel and the characters you talk to it
it looked great and I felt like they
kept pushing that all the way to three
and this one it's just like this is what
this is next generation this is what it
looks like like some of the textures and
characters looks better in three I think
there's a lot of similarities to
something like fallout 4 in terms of
presentation where it does feel like
right this doesn't belong in this
generation something something is amiss
here having quit fallout 4 I can like
kind of understand maybe why that is
although like even though I gave it at
nine like I still think the game could
looks a lot better it's the things I'm
seeing in this game that looks so good
in comparison to the characters that
makes me wonder like well wait why why
wasn't that that generosity at least
spread a little bit further across the
game like the planets you go to you look
pretty cool the art direction like in
the Normandy and or not in the Normandy
excuse me in the tempest like that
stuff's pretty cool I'd say but the
characters fell flat um one thing has
been bothering me a lot if the
characters have dead eyes yes how
they're almost too alive makes like
romancing must be so awkward that's just
what I've been thinking about aliens I
just keep thinking about that just go
for the aliens yeah do they have
normalize the ones well the ones that
don't have salarians with the giant eyes
look more normal than human beings yeah
so Charlotte cuts thank you for your
question and then once I was a little
light on Twitter said does in drama does
writing and tone remain childish or does
develop as the game goes on and the
characters grow okay there there is one
instance when I was talking about eyes
and we're talking about humour that I
don't know if anyone else caught it but
like I was watching you play yesterday I
was like did you see the saris eyes just
now and you're like what no there's the
cutscene really early on with is it on
sorry or oh sorry I'm sorry like okay
yes I thought you're thinking of a Z
he's pretty funny there's there's like a
scene where something like really
serious is happening and it's like
really early in the game and right
before it cuts away because sorry like
like rolls her eyes in this super
comedic fashion and I don't know if it's
like a glitch of like the eye-tracking
or not they come out of her head but I
almost I actually can't wait to put a
gif of that online because I think it's
super straight alright unintentional
humor that's the tone is pretty similar
to the other ones though so those are
our early impressions of Mass Effect
Andromeda like I said I've played more
than those first two hours
Scott Butterworth will have his review
up Monday yes sir
March 20th it releases on the 21st if
you have early access EA early access
you could play what we were talking
about right now alright tomorrow yes
tomorrow Thursday March 16th
thank you so yeah well have we have more
Mass Effect stuff coming out on gamespot
we will be talking more about in drama
as the days go by and we approach the
embargo on Monday and then we'll have
more stuff up around when the game
releases next week and I'm sure we'll
talk more about it next week doing a
live stream to it one of the multiplayer
multiplayer Mass Effect Andromeda
livestream today here at GameSpot at one
o'clock in about an hour 2 o'clock 2
o'clock
John Luke just voice of God told us some
strange man in our rafters just told us
that that stream is at 2 o'clock so
stick around for that
[Music]